hey
everybody I
suppose I should start by
apologizing for picking such an odd
topic but this has been on my mind
lately and last year was a doozy for
some of this
[Music]
stuff
so uh YouTuber apology
videos they sure suck don't they I mean
yeah in some cases for very specific
reasons and I'll talk a little bit about
some of them but this is not a specific
analysis of Any Given apology video I
just found myself thinking about the
general fact that has there ever been a
good or successful or just not
embarrassing YouTuber apology
video I'm not sure there ever has they
never seem to work they never seem to
help whatever the situation is and they
are often incredibly memeable for the
worst reasons but
why why does nobody on this platform
know how to
apologize there are actually reasons for
that that's kind of what I what I want
to talk
about now uh as I said I don't want to
dive too far into any of the specifics
of why any given YouTuber has or has not
had to issue apologies I will cite some
specific examples but only to be
illustrative of the kind of thing that I
am talking about obviously the two big
ones from last year were James Summerton
and Colleen
Ballinger yeah those were big quick
overview James Summerton was
uh I'll I'll say accused but it was it
was basically proven very extensively
was a massive plagiarist and also liar
of a YouTube essayist he presented stuff
as if he had done research when in fact
he just stole other people's words and
presented them as his own and he tried
to issue an apology video and it went
very badly and he took it down pretty
quickly as t to be the fate of most
apology videos they don't stay up long
as a rule then there was Colleen
Ballinger who had some very troubling
allegations in regards to how she
behaved around some of her younger fans
and she opted to address that by playing
the
ukulele yeah why do any of these folks
think this stuff's going to work well
because they're caught in a Crossroads
the thing is
doing this as a job puts you in a weird
place where like you're you but you're
also a business and this isn't about
like necessarily the parasocial end of
it is like oh you think you know me but
you don't really know me like that
factors in a little but I mean more just
you have to apologize as a
person but you also have to try and
apologize as a
business and those are two things that
don't go well together businesses
issuing apologies well their priority
has to be we promise we'll do better
don't stop um consuming our product
whatever that might be don't stop buying
whatever we make don't stop watching
whatever we put out or uh a very common
thing in the video game realm is what's
known as the solemn jpeg the apology for
usually massively buggy or U
misrepresented launches of video games
and they also don't really work but they
keep being put out because they have to
put out something and of course they
don't work it's Bas level corporate
padum like they're just saying the
things that they think maybe people will
be less mad at us if we say this and
then they just try and move forward but
like it's very we need to protect the
company and uh save face as a business
that's that's what these things are
meant to do they almost never work but
like that's its
purpose now if you're wronged by someone
in your personal life and you want a
personal
apology what you expect out of that is
an acknowledgement of the harm that was
caused a
validation of your pain if what they did
hurt you in specific and not just a
vague pledge to do better but showing a
concrete understanding of what it is
that this person did wrong and what
steps they need to take in order to get
better and possibly the most important
thing no actual expectation of being
forgiven nothing undercuts an apology
faster than the underlying sense of you
really desperately want me to forgive
you don't you cuz the best apologies in
my opinion are ones that are issued in
full acknowledgement of what happened
but are not done presuming that you are
you will therefore forgive me because I
apologized now corporations can't do
that because they need you to keep
consuming their their products
individuals can like it hurts if you've
done something wrong and if you've
apologized for it if that person doesn't
forgive you and they are now gone from
your life that can still
hurt but that's also something that a
good personal apology should should
carry you know that sense of I
understand if I am losing you because of
what I
did again businesses they can try and do
that but nobody buys it because they
don't want you to go away they want you
to keep spending
money and
YouTubers caught smack dab in the middle
of
this because we have to present the
apologies as a person
but we have to do it on behalf of a
business whether or not any given
YouTuber is big enough to have actually
formed a corporation and have employees
that's not the point the point is you
yourself are the business unless you are
part of a larger organization where you
are not the entirety of it and that's
why in some cases where the person at
issue has not been you know the entire
thing it wasn't their personal Channel
they were part of something larger so
like Ned from the triy guys or Philip M
over at IGN they just got fired because
you know they can issue whatever
personal apologies they want but you're
gone from this business but for somebody
like James Summerton like Colleen
Ballinger hell like me what is this
channel if I'm not here nobody else is
going to do this so you have to try and
issue an apology
for stuff that you most likely did as a
person rather than as a business because
a business apology is about like we we
need to form formulate better plans and
better policies and whatnot but like
when YouTubers get in trouble it's
usually for something they did as a
person not because of a bad business
venture that sometimes happen but that
rarely gets to the level of some of the
stuff that I'm more referring
to so how do you do that how do you
issue an
apology that will cover for your
personal harm that you've
done but will also do the business thing
of being like I pledge to do better
please continue to support me and I
think the short answer is you can't like
legitimately you can't because that key
to the personal apology that acceptance
of if I lose this
connection then I understand and I
accept those consequences if this is
your living that is you conceding the
fact that oh I don't have a job anymore
and I think that's why say James
Summerton issued the apology that he did
and again I'm not going to break it down
I don't want to for starters but I
suspect that a big part of why he issued
an apology at all whether you think it
was good or bad it was bad but I suspect
part of the reason he did it at all was
because the alternative is to find a
completely different line of
work and I think he needs to come to
terms with the fact that that's what he
needs to do the one thing I will
highlight that he did in the video is he
said I still have videos I want to
make but I do want to make videos again
sometime which is Rich coming from a guy
who is just outed as effectively not
making his own videos you didn't write
them what do you mean you still have
videos you want to make you didn't make
it anything you read a script of stolen
words and then you plugged it into an
editing suite and vomited it onto the
internet what do you mean you have
videos you still want to make I think
the actual truth behind that is I still
want this to be my living cuz I don't
want to have to start from zero in
another business another
career uh with no immediate prospects
because I can't build off of what I had
on
YouTube that is my presump asson as
being the actual reality
but as an apology for having personally
wronged all the people that you stole
your work from no that doesn't work and
like there's all the general tactics
that not just Summerton but lots of
YouTuber or apology videos have put as
little emphasis and as few specifics as
possible on what it is you actually did
don't specifically mention any body that
you wronged if you think you can get
away with it do not talk in specifics
about what you did just say I'm sorry
and focus the apology on letting down
your
audience not on the people you actually
harmed you don't want to bring them up
if you can get away with it and then
there's the more sleazy stuff that may
or may not factor in you know calling it
an attack from people setting somebody
else to take the blame the that stuff's
often in the
mix but none of this
works because again no matter how you're
trying to cover for your
business it's still you in front of a
camera issuing a personal
apology but you're doing it for a
business so you can't give the kind of
apology that might actually land
well cuz you want to keep the business
running or maybe you need to keep the
business running I don't want to presume
what anybody
situation is or isn't in terms of
finances but those two conflicts they
will never ever work out and I think
that's also part of why we get some
really weird stuff like Colleen
Ballinger like James Summerton is easier
to parse why he did what he did coling
Ballinger is harder because like what
were you possibly
thinking and while I'm generally uh
avoid any kind of armchair diagnoses of
what is going on in somebody's
head I would not be shocked if part of
her thought process was
well I can't just own up to what
happened and apologize for that because
that'll be the end of everything I've
made uh so I'll swing for the fences and
I'll throw a curveball and I'll do
something
weird it didn't work but when you're in
a when you're in a truly no win
situation I can't say I blame somebody
for swinging for the
fences I guess I can blame them for
swinging for the fences with a ukulele
but I feel like that's kind of a factor
in there somewhere and the thing is I'm
going to cite someone who for a while
was my go-to example for this is how you
apologize for this stuff unfortunately
and I'll mention this again when I get
to the end of the example um I have to
caveat this with even this guy didn't
stick The Landing I will still cite him
as the best approach when things broke
Warren Ellis is a writer he is a comic
book writer a novelist he's written TV
shows wrote some of my favorite Comics
some of my favorite shows he had a
fairly large number of credible
accusations of uh abusive relationship
Dynamic
behavior and what he did when that came
out was he said
listen to these women I am going to go
away quick addition from the editing
phase his initial statement was slightly
more defensive with a few denials that I
honestly had not remembered I'm still
going to let this go forward as I
originally stated it because I think my
memory of what he did is still what I
think people should do but I just want
to be clear that no even he in his
initial statement was not quite what I
was uh remembering it as maybe I should
have checked before I sat down to record
haha
he basically cancelled all of the work
that he was doing and he vanished off
social media and he made a pledge to
actually communicate with these women
who are kind of organized into uh a bit
of a group you know because they had
been swapping stories about what he put
them through and he had a little bit of
that sort of you know I didn't
understand the power and balance of the
relationships that I did but it it
didn't come across as an excuse it came
across as an explanation hey just a
quick addendum to this while I believe
it is possible to be sincere when
someone expresses I did not realize that
the power Dynamic I was in was
inequitable or they didn't realize the
full nature of how what they were doing
is wrong can work there does need to be
some degree of posibility to it in other
words while it in no way excuses
anything I can buy that a successful man
with a degree of influence and power
doesn't fully grasp the power IM balance
that happens when he gets involved with
people it's much harder for me to buy
that somebody say to pull a random
example that I just completely made up
didn't realize it wasn't okay to put out
cigarettes on another person's body when
that was not something consented to or
desired so you know saying I didn't
realize that this was a problem needs a
level of plausibility which I felt at
least initially Ellis had but again the
big emphasis that he put forward is
believe these women I need to go away
and try and sort my stuff
out and I honestly think that's the best
thing anybody can do under these
situations but again with a YouTuber
unless you've got yourself a really nice
Nest Egg a really good safety net some
Investments some other means of income
that isn't dependent on you cranking out
your regular content on a regular
basis yeah you might not be able to just
go away I'm sure the reason he could is
because he's had a fairly lengthy career
and if he wasn't totally mismanaging his
money residuals alone should keep him
okay now as I said unfortunately even he
couldn't stick The Landing because the
word from the women who spoke about the
issues that they had with him have since
said that while he did begin
communicating with them initially as he
said he would he did not take to heart
or seem to take on board what they
actually said or what they recommended
would be the best things for him to do
moving forward and while he hasn't
really
reemerged that was really disappointing
to see so even the one guy that I can
point to and go see that's a good
apology even he blew it in the end he
seems to have come to a conclusion that
well I know how to fix uh my problems
better than the people who I actually
harmed so I'm not really going to be
listening to you and whether he ever
sorts his nonsense out I don't know I
don't know the guy personally but that
was disappointing
regardless I think again he did the one
thing that YouTubers can't do go
away it's hard for anybody with a career
to just stop doing that thing but here
especially in the attention economy
where the algorithm forgets you unless
you are already somebody with over a
million
subscribers The algorithm is very quick
to forget you if you are someone with a
regular schedule of content and you just
stop and that puts the business pressure
onto personal situations and again these
two things that is not a happy
marriage I don't really have an ultimate
point that I'm building to it was just
something that I found myself thinking
about like why do all these apologies
suck why do they never
work I think it's the nature of the
Beast
I think unless you are prepared to
completely walk away from this line of
work um at least temporarily and
therefore risk not being able to regain
your momentum ever
again then yeah the apologies are going
to suck and the thing is some of these
people who have issued these apologies
did go away after the apology bombed
though I have no doubt had the apology
worked they would not have just gone
away and avoided all public scrutiny or
putting stuff out or you know waited for
a long time whatever it is they chose to
do they fairly regularly do after the
apology bombs and the
apology always
bombs and I think it probably always
will so those are my thoughts on that
what are your thoughts on this I I try
to avoid like getting into the weeds of
drama and what specific people did or
didn't do like I know people are going
to cite examp samples down in the
comments but please don't get into
fights with each other about who did
what to who or whatever cuz that was not
the point of this video and I really
don't want to be clearing out the
comments of that stuff because it gets
real toxic real fast and then I have to
just start deleting whole threads of
conversations and I don't like doing
that please don't make
me so you know no matter what your
feelings are even if you feel somebody
else posted something very wrong just
try not to fight in the comments okay
I'd appreciate it
but uh if you can keep it sful drop
something down in the comments we'll
talk about it patreon pays the bills and
enables me to do this as my living even
if you can help me out that way like a
share a subscribe they all help me out
don't worry too much about it though
what I really want you to remember is
that you are beautiful you are valid and
you are
loved you are the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned and I won't
apologize ol for
[Music]
it drum roll for my highest supporting
patrons Robin Moore Z Lula goddess Ela
Oliver B T Rock the thing that goes dink
in the anime Ruth go of the gazarian
solitary pictures olrick Bogden geek
filter Linda Walters Toby Jackson Jen
Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks fomi likes
the poodle Robin Powell t love czy
scrapit Angry caspero Dave Hall quite
bearish Rosalyn Bennett pal baraba jle
and miror G thanks so
[Music]
[Applause]
much
[Music]
no